so much for the torn acl keeping bud
dupree from getting paid
in free agency the tennessee titans
swoop in
day one and get dupree done now
i've seen it's a multi-year contract
with an annual average of 16 and a half
million
right tell me how much is guaranteed and
that doesn't tell me anything beyond the
fact that he has a team
and that if he's healthy he'll get paid
but he's going to have to prove himself
and if it's a multi-year deal chances
are
it will be a lot like the deal in some
respects a lot like the deal that drew
brees did 15 years ago
two days ago six years 60 million but
there was a huge
option payment after the first year if
the guy's healthy the team keeps him
that's better for the team than the
one-year deal because if you just do the
one-year deal
hey you come back you prove yourself you
establish yourself and we got no way to
keep you so i bet that there's some
trigger like that some major bonus year
two that if bud duprey's healthy and
plays well the titans have a
a device for keeping him around that
what was the first thing that came to
mind when you saw that deal
yeah i mean that you know a little bit
of what you're saying i think yeah that
was one of the more wow deals that
that uh went across for for me yesterday
because i just didn't know i mean first
off yeah he's got a torn acl that he did
in week 10 of the nfl season he's not
ready right now
you know he probably won't be totally a
hundred percent full sil
you know all cylinders go come training
camp or anything like that
so i guess that was one of the shockers
of the day there's no doubt but man
i mean do they need him holy cow how
many times did we talk about that last
year they can't rush the passer they got
nobody impressive on their front
seven that's scary dupries is stutt he
is an
awesome football player when he's
healthy and
i didn't think a team would maybe be
this aggressive with him right there on
the first day of free agency but when
healthy
he fits everything that mike vrabel
would want for his defense
yeah let's wait for the details but good
for him that he landed so quickly
to nicole autry also to the titans what
was the first word that came to mind
when you saw that well it's it's
you know it's like the new england
versatility thing there
again there's a lot of similarities with
that defense dupree can play 3-4 outside
linebacker
he can put his hands on the ground and
play 4-3 defense and
deniko atrey can play 4-3 defensive end
or you can bump him inside and he can
play defensive tackle
and use athleticism against those guys
so
they needed improvements and difference
makers and disruptors on their front and
both of these guys are that and
especially bud dupree
when he's healthy so good good signings
by john robinson and mike vrable
yeah and jadavian clowney most likely
won't be back
with the tennessee titans when you see
that investment get made in day one on
gaza on the outside
raiders whoa grabbing yannick and gaque
on a two-year deal first word that came
to mind when you saw that well
need thank god i mean jeez you need a
pass rusher you're going to run that
scheme you know
first off they've had no pass rusher
ever since gruden's been there they
couldn't sign khalil mack because
like you talked about earlier you know
in the show i don't think they had the
cold hard cash to actually pay them
you know so that they haven't had that
guy in the gruden era
yannick and gawkway is a guy that fits
exactly perfect
with the scheme he was drafted by gus
bradley in jacksonville when gus was the
head coach there
so it makes sense from all you know
angles here
and it's a team need a system fit and
13 million dollars is certainly
nothing crazy for a guy coming off the
edge trying to be your sack master and
i think the raiders can certainly
swallow that price tag and be happy they
got a really good football player in in
gaque
again joey bose is getting 27 million a
year
13 years right they're getting two years
out of yannick and gawkway
for less than what the chargers are
paying joey bosa for one year
and uh poor and gawkway just he never
can line it up just right right
to get that big payday that he earned
early in his career with the
jacksonville jaguars leonard floyd
somehow the ramp i still have yet to see
what the rams are going to do to get
under the cap by tomorrow at 4 p.m
eastern 1 p.m pacific it's even earlier
for them
they better be working to reduce some of
these cap numbers because here's leonard
floyd on a four-year 64 million dollar
deal to stay put with the rams
was the first thing that came to mind
when you saw that well one of my
favorite deals of the day
i mean first off this is like you know
he's one of he's chris sims all pro team
right here
it's one of my favorite players in
football you talk about like guys who
don't get enough notoriety
you know he'd be like in my robin hood
like you know take from the rich give to
the
give to the poor this guy like is a
special special football player
i don't give a damn what is saxar he is
the king of f the play up mike he's one
of those guys on the edge that's just
way more disruption and value to a
defense than the statistics
or the stat books or you know anything
like that can show
so hey best defense in football
he can do it all on the edge he's an
awesome football player
yeah is he going to be a consistently a
double digit sack guy probably not he's
probably going to be always in that
seven
eight sacks a year range but it's all
the other things he can do
too uh that was big move by them i just
yeah i'm like you mike i just go
how are they gonna make this work what
what's gonna go on here
they're gonna have to do some serious
movement here
over the next 24 hours to get under the
cap
absolutely they're gonna have to figure
it out there's some restructuring they
can do we had an item over the weekend
at pft
identifying all of their guys making two
and a half million or more in salary who
would be candidates for a restructuring
where you take their salary
reduce it to the minimum and the rest of
it becomes a signing bonus that gets
spread over multiple years and creates
current your cab space you're kicking
the can
you're asking for trouble later but the
rams look at that 38 million
above the cap they're in the worst
position right now and by the way
yeah you mentioned the robin hood
catchphrase
right of robbing from the rich and
giving to the poor sure
it immediately reminded me of something
that our friends in the uk and in
ireland watching on sky sports surely
are aware of
from the old monty python's flying
circus there was a sketch
featuring a gentleman named dennis moore
who would rob from the poor
and give to the rich kind of got the
whole thing what a jerk that guy
is that was that was yeah well the la
the line was
rob's from the poor and gives to the
rich stupid
word that rhymes with rich that was the
that was the song
the monty python's
stays in detroit with his brother it
would have been awkward
would have been awkward if okwara had
left given they drafted his brother last
year out of notre dame
uh three-year deal 39 million first word
that came to mind on that like gritty
tough he fits exactly like what dan
campbell would want i would expect you
know
again like yeah edge rusher the place to
run
well you can kick him inside every now
and then
but i think has the attitude and the
kind of style of play where they just go
no he fits
you know what we want to do and and
that's where i think it makes sense and
again
they're a team too where you just look
at them and you go well they don't have
a lot of difference makers there
to begin with so he's one of the few
they got
they didn't have to pay huge huge money
to him that makes sense he's got
everything else you want you know off
the field too to go along with it
yeah um i agree with that completely i'm
just i'm pausing here because i got the
full jameis winston contract
okay that's a base salary of 5.5 million
well signing bonus of four and a half
million so he gets that
right out of the gates base salary of a
million everything else is in the form
of
incentives playing time wins playoff
wins team achievements passing yards
completion percentage yadda yadda with a
couple avoidable years on the back end
so they can spread that money out from
the signing bonus so sorry for the
sorry for the deviation there but i was
really curious to see what yeah i hear
you five and a half million
for a quarterback base salary i mean
that's he's
he essentially has the cam newton deal
with a higher
floor and a lower ceiling yeah that's
essentially what jameis winston has in
new orleans all right uh trey
hendrickson this one fascinated me
because carl austin goes from the
bengals to the jets
for three years 45. trey hendrickson
passed rusher from the saints to the
bengals four years and 60
uh my first reaction was holy crap
this is this is not what the bengals do
no they don't throw around money like
this especially on the first day of free
agency what was your thought with
hendrickson going well
it made me think just like right off the
bat like what i mean did they how badly
do they want carl lawson did they just
lose out
on you know just an arms race there for
a cash
henderson is the one guy i'm really
intrigued by you know in free agency
i mean yes he's a real good player i i i
do
look at it a little bit and go it was a
little bit of a flash in the pan type of
year
where he had this special year plays
really hard definitely there's no doubt
about that
we did see him kind of like disappear
towards the end of the year a little bit
too
to where he certainly didn't pop and and
some of the must-have
big moments um but i i think the
the once they lose carl lawson you know
you got geno atkins who's still good
getting up there in years but it goes to
the same thing
there's just not a lot to talk about in
the front seven of the cincinnati
bengals
so okay here here goes a guy that you
know fits a role
certainly can be disrupted and come off
the edge and they need some some more
difference makers on their front seven
to go along with it
and it's not a bad you know price tag
but but
more expensive than i guess i was
expecting for trey hendrickson
i will say that six and a half sacks in
his first three years combined
right with the saints 15 and a half
sacks last year
the right year to do it that's the year
you parlay it into big money
but you know one of the one of the
caveats that came to mind yeah when you
consider
that it was three years 45 for carl loss
to go to the jets and four years
60 the same rate 15 million a year for
hendrickson
in free agency the team that
employed the player knows that player
better than anyone yes right
and and when you let him walk away yeah
if you've got 15 million a year budgeted
and i don't know the back story here
maybe they got caught flat-footed with
carl lawson and they panicked but
if they're talking to lawson and they're
talking to hendrickson
and they're willing to go 15 for
hendrickson but not 15 for lawson and
someone else swoops in and does it it's
just
i always worry that that the new team
you know is projecting to an extent what
are you relying upon like the patriots
well we played him last year well
you saw him for one week the team he
played for us on for 17.
that i saw i'm you know these guys who
are available
are available for a reason they're
available because the team that has
employed them
in most cases from multiple years has
decided
we're good we'll we'll go elsewhere and
and that always
that's one of the things that always
concerns me about free agency no i i
hear you
you know and in lawson there is a little
bit of an injury history and those type
of things to go along with it
so maybe there's that aspect you know
maybe
maybe just though the vision of the
bengals defense is they want a little
bit of a different type of guy there
lawson may be a pure pass rusher
hendrickson a little bit more of like
yes the pass rusher plays the run well
does those type of things
but i hear you there there's definitely
some concern there but
you know like i like you you'd argue
that and i'd balance also too with
hendrickson
just like you said it's only one year
and he was you know on maybe the best
defensive line in football or certainly
one of the top three or four
so it wasn't like you could like double
him and go all over them that way
and and the other thing too mike and i
was trying to pull it up as we were
sitting here talking
the one thing i cuz i remember seeing
yesterday it basically i thought
hendrickson's deal
they could get out after one year where
it could be like a one-year
uh 20 million dollar deal and i got it
here they could
they'd have a little dead money in year
two but i think they protect themselves
a little in that fashion too to where
yeah
lawson got 33 million guaranteed right
and that's a little different too
the idea of getting out of a deal after
20 million for one i know is not ideal
though but
i hear what you're saying hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports